had a good afternoon we start with
breaking news and a new poll of
conservative party members has found
that more than half think Liz truss
should resign as prime minister you'll
remember it was conservative party
members who voted her in to replace
Boris Johnson well let's get the details
from our Deputy political editor Sam
Coates and Sam this was a survey of some
five more than 500 conservative party
members uh what have they told you
that's right Jane what a remarkable
turnaround in just a matter of weeks
from the people who put Liz truss in
number 10 now a majority appear to want
them out that's the conclusion of a
yougov survey taken in the last few days
of Tory party members let's look at the
headline results of the 530 conservative
members polled over the last two days
55 have told you gov that they believe
the Prime Minister should resign now and
when asked who should take over from Liz
Truss
Boris Johnson comes top 32 percent say
that the former prime minister should
take over the role once more he of
course was elected uh in 2019 the one
with a democratic mandate the members
want to go back to him with Rishi sunac
coming second on 23 of the vote and Ben
Wallace coming third so a really
striking set of results there showing
that the chaos of the last few days both
in the market and at Conservative Party
Conference and this week with the firing
of quasiquarting on Friday and the
u-turns by Jeremy Hunt yesterday having
a very real impact on what Tori members
think of Liz Trust
uh Sam they really are quite uh
astonishing figures aren't they they